wegen diesem sternchen hier gehen sich
akademiker und aktivisten schon seit
jahren an die gurgel
oder sollte ich lieber akademiker innen
und aktivistinnen sagen und damit sind
wir schon mittendrin in der diskussion
um das sogenannte gender sternchen
[Musik]
erst vor kurzem hat der duden wo ist da
das wort gender sternchen in den noblen
club der offiziellen deutschen wörter
aufgenommen und die begründung der
redaktion dafür war dass sich dieses
gender sternchen halt immer mehr
durchsetzen würde
dafür gab es dann für den einen gerühmte
nasen und von den anderen ablaufen der
streit um das gender sternchen der ist
aber eigentlich im kern ein streit um
geschlechtergerechte sprache
das heißt auf der einen seite stehen die
die so weitermachen wollen wie bisher
also die wollen daran festhalten dass
weiterhin die männliche form für
personen und berufe verwendet wird auch
wenn es eine weibliche formen gibt und
auf der anderen seite stehen die die
sagen sorry es geht gar nicht denn wenn
nicht nur männer gemeint sind dann kann
man das doch bitte schön auch so sagen
damit ihr euch in diesem streit jetzt
selber eine meinung bilden könnte da
will ich euch zunächst mal jeweils drei
argumente von beiden seiten bringen und
danach habe ich dann vorschläge für euch
wie wir in diesem konflikt vielleicht
doch noch zu einem konsens kommen können
wir fangen an mit runde eins das pro
argument und das lautet nicht alle
fühlen sich durch die männliche form
auch angesprochen und das ist jetzt kein
geführtes argument so aus dem bauch raus
das haben tatsächlich schon sehr viele
studien seit den 1980 er jahren gezeigt
denn wer zum beispiel moderator hört
oder bäcker oder lehrer
der denkt nachweislich häufiger und
schneller an männer als auch frauen eine
studie von 2015 die hat sogar gezeigt
dass die männliche form uns unterbewusst
in der berufs beeinflussen kann
die forschenden haben damals
schülerinnen und schülern verschiedene
berufsbezeichnungen vorgestellt zb
automechaniker und einmal wurde nur die
männliche form verwendet und das andere
mal die männliche und die weibliche form
also automechanikerin und automechaniker
das ergebnis davon war dass wenn beide
formen verwendet wurden dass ich dann
kinder also mädchen und jungen den
eher zugetraut haben und das war
besonders auch bei diesen sogenannten
typisch männlichen berufen der falten
aber die gegenseite kommt damit contra
argument 1 und sie sich völlig sicher
die männliche form des wortes reicht aus
auch der bundesgerichtshof hat schon so
argumentiert der hat gesagt für frauen
gebe es keine benachteiligung wenn statt
der weiblichen form die männliche form
eines wortes benutzt werde das sei
schließlich allgemeine sprachgebrauch
und deswegen würde damit zitat keine
geringschätzung gegenüber personen zutat
ende zum ausdruck gebracht die nicht
männlich sind
das urteil geht zurück auf eine klage
einer 82-jährigen sparkassenkunden die
hatte nämlich gefordert dass bank
formulare auch eine weibliche anrede
enthalten müssten
denn in den formularen von ihrer bank da
war immer nur von kunden oder vom
kontoinhaber die rede und sie von das
diskriminierend aber laut
bundesgerichtshof muss sie sich damit
abfinden und auch nach den aktuellen
rechts schreiber regel ist es
tatsächlich so dass das geschlecht eines
namens nicht mit dem natürlichen
geschlecht übereinstimmen muss das heißt
jetzt zum beispiel konkret ein polizist
und eine polizistin sind zusammen die
polizisten und das geht auch wenn einer
gruppe überwiegend aus frauen besteht
und sogar wenn man von dem polizisten
spricht kann damit einer frau gemeint
sein
dieses argument das nutzt auch der
verein deutsche sprache der hat eine
petition ins leben gerufen die heißt
schluss mit gender und fuge und waren
hat er das unter anderem genau so
begründet diese petition ist übrigens
seit märz 2009 10 von 77.000 man
unterschrieben wurden die befürworter
des gender sternchen die sehen das ganz
anders
für sie ist die anerkennung von
geschlechter vielfalt einer der
zentralen gründe für das sternchen und
damit 8 und der runde zwei das zweite
pro argument lautet das gender sternchen
berücksichtigt alle geschlechter das
sagen zum beispiel die grünen die
evangelische kirche in deutschland und
auch der deutsche frauenrat dennis
berücksichtigt eben nicht nur ein
binäres geschlechts system also hier
männer auf den einen und frauen auf der
anderen seite dass man das
berücksichtigt auch alle die sich eben
keinem der beiden geschlechter ganz
eindeutig zuordnen können oder wollen
beim sprechen wird das durch diese
kleine pause deutlich gemacht und dann
sind zum beispiel mit zuschauer
innen alle gemeint also männliche
weibliche und diverse menschen mit einem
gender sternchen zeige ich also bewusst
allen angesprochenen dass ich sie in
ihrer identität anerkenne und das ist
eben den befürworterinnen wichtig denn
alle die sich nicht in dieses gängige
geschlecht system aus männlich und
weiblich einordnen können oder wollen
die hausherren schon schwer in unserer
gesellschaft diese menschen werden oft
diskriminiert deswegen und sie leiden
auch unter sozialer ungleichheit und für
sie könnte dieses gender sternchen
deswegen ein wichtiges signal zur
anerkennung sein das sagt zumindest die
pro seite aber für die gegenseite steht
etwas ganz anderes im vordergrund
nämlich die recht schreibt wege sie
konnte hart contra argument 2 die
verwendung des gender sternchens
entspricht nicht den regeln deutsche
rechtschreibung und das würde zu fehlern
führen so argumentiert zum beispiel auch
die gesellschaft für deutsche sprache
abgekürzt gfds oder gibt's wenn durch
die verwendung des gender sternchens da
hörten grammatikalisch falsche form
entstehen
und damit haben sie in einigen fällen ja
auch durchaus recht denn aus dem baur
oder der bäuerin würde durch das
sternchen ein bauer in und das ist nicht
nur die falsche form das würde außerdem
den lesefluss stören das sagt zumindest
die gfds
und auch der rechtschreib grad konnte
sich bislang nicht darauf einigen dass
gender sternchen anzuerkennen und weil
dieser recht schreibt die amtliche
deutsche rechtschreibung festlegt ist
bislang offiziell immer noch ein
rechtschreibfehler
obwohl es im duden steht aber
rechtschreibung regeln sind nichts für
die ewigkeit und auch das sternchen das
könne man lernen das sagen zumindest die
sternchen fans und damit willkommen in
runde drei
das dritte pro argument lautet das
gender sternchen ist verständlich und
sprache ändert sich sowieso ich meine
klar konsequenz sein das ist nicht immer
einfach und manche begriffe die können
durch das sternchen erst mal kompliziert
erscheinen aber die befürworter ihnen
sagen dass es natürlich trotzdem möglich
ist von bürger/innen meister innen zu
sprechen wenn man das denn will
und das kann einem ja auch wirklich
niemand verbieten ausser klar wenn
deutsch lehrer innen oder professorinnen
was dagegen haben die könnten damit den
rotstift an kommt mal so richtig rechts
schreiber konform ist das ja nicht aber
sonst gern wenn einem support mit
sternchen zu langes dann kann man ja
auch ein neues wort als nun sagen die
befürworter erinnern die das dann zum
beispiel mit stadtoberhäuptern die
befürworterinnen weisen nämlich darauf
hin dass sie sprach er die ganze zeit
ändert und das können wir ja auch wenn
man selber sehen
ich meine vor zehn jahren da hätte von
niemandem plan gehabt was bitte social
distanz sein soll werden noch keine
ahnung gehabt was passiert wenn man
kinder hat und stabil
das war damals noch ein nettes wort für
fällt also nicht so nett doch für viele
gegner ist diese sternchen keine debatte
die etwas mit dem alltag von den meisten
menschen zu tun hat sie finden im
gegenteil das ist eher so ein
überhitztes und überschätztes
diskussionsthema im spannungsfeld
zwischen feminismus sprachwissenschaften
und politik und damit kommen wir zum
letzten contra argumente und das lautet
das gender sternchen ist für die meisten
menschen überhaupt nicht relevant
und tatsächlich gibt ihnen da eine insa
umfrage von 2020 recht okay muss man
sagen die wurde auch im auftrag des
vereins deutsche sprache durchgeführt
und die sind ja gegen das gender
sternchen aber laut dieser umfrage gaben
62 prozent der befragten an dass sie
gendern unwichtig finden neun von zehn
befragten sagten außerdem dass sie in
ihrer privaten zeit überhaupt nicht
ändern würden und drei viertel von ihnen
würden das auch beruflich nicht tun
das kann natürlich dazu führen dass da
so ein gewisser grad besteht zwischen
dem die das gender sternchen unbedingt
offiziell machen wollen und alles dafür
tun und denen die nicht verstehen warum
sie jetzt auf einmal anders schreiben um
anders reden sollen als bislang
denn nicht vergessen menschen lieben das
gewohnte und deswegen waren auch
sprachwissenschaftler wie peter
eisenberg tor vor dass gender sternchen
quasi von oben festzulegen
er meint es gibt niemanden der das recht
hat man eine sprache einzugreifen so das
waren jetzt jeweils drei pro und drei
contra argumente für oder gegen das
gender sternchen
damit ihr nicht komplett durcheinander
kommt fassen wir das ganze jetzt noch
mal kurz zusammen also die menschen
wieder spender sternchen wir für worten
die sagen die männliche form wird von
vielen nur als männlich verstanden und
deswegen fühlen sie sich ausgeschlossen
alle geschlechter und nicht nur männer
und frauen werden damit berücksichtigt
und das dritte argument es geht halt sie
nicht schnell sich an diesen gender
stern zu gewöhnen
die gegner die in diesem fall nicht
gegner innen genannt werden wollen die
sagen erstens das gender sternchen
verstößt gegen die regeln der deutschen
rechtschreibung und führt deswegen so zu
fehlern
zweitens die männliche form reicht
völlig aus weil sie grammatikalisch eben
alle meint nicht nur männer
und drittens dass es mit diskussion die
mit dem alltag von vielen leuten
überhaupt nichts zu tun hat
tja also das ist ja schon irgendwie
sogar ziemlich festgefahrene situation
und wenn er jetzt die hände in die luft
wirft und sagt ey
sorry ich hab echt keine ahnung wer da
jetzt recht hat dann kann ich das nicht
gut verstehen
aber vielleicht gibt es ja so was die
lösung für eine einheitsregierung oder
sogar ein kompromiss drucken wir doch
mal die männliche form wird aktiv von
der vorstellung einer rein männlichen
gruppe gelöst dann gab es nämlich dieses
problem mit den ländern gar nicht mehr
aber dafür müsste vor allem das deutsche
bildungssystem in die verantwortung
gehen
das heißt von der kita bis zur uni müsse
auf allen ebenen immer wieder eindeutig
kommuniziert werden die männliche form
gilt für alle und nicht nur für männer
und das praktisch umzusetzen dann müsste
man an den unterrichtsmaterialien zum
beispiel arbeiten ja wenn alle
geschlechter in schulbüchern
repräsentiert werden und zwar ohne
schubladendenken also wie das hier zum
beispiel augenblick wo ist es da der
klempner ist der mann
denn neben dem klo steht und sich
kümmert und die frau guckt bild wenn man
auch sowas verzichtet und klar macht
dass ein klempner auch eine frau sein
kann
dann könnte das ein beitrag dazu leisten
dass dieses wort klempner als form für
alle wahrgenommen
und da könnten ja auch einfach die
vielfalt an schreibweisen zu lassen also
der ständer sternchen schrägstrich und
dem doppelpunkt oder was euch noch so
einfällt kann man noch nicht so gut
lesen gerade egal
die frage ist ja nämlich ob wir bei dem
thema überhaupt eine einheits regelung
wollen
anatol stefanowitsch der
sprachwissenschaftler an der freien
universität berlin
der würde diese frage wohl derzeit noch
mit klaren nein beantworten einige
behörden würden reihenweise aufs gender
sternchen umschalten sagte im
deutschlandfunk und es dann völlig
gedankenlos nutzen und ja das kann ja
auch nicht sinn der sache sein
und überhaupt es kann ja auch zum
nachdenken anregen dass wir uns noch
nicht festlegen was wir jetzt benutzen
nur dass wir vielfalt zulassen und damit
eben auch zeigen dass die debatte um
geschlechtergerechtigkeit noch lange
nicht vorbei ist und am ende findet sich
ja möglicherweise ganz natürlich nur
form die für die meisten passt so jetzt
habe ich ganz schön viel erzählt
deswegen würde ich sagen sollte immer
daran welchen dieser konsens vorschläge
findet ihr denn am sinnvollsten oder
habt ihr vielleicht machen wir ganz
andere idee die wir nicht hatten die wir
diesen streit lösen können lasst es
nicht wissen gibt mir einen kommentar
gibt mir ein abo like ihr kennt das
ganze spiel wir gucken rein wir melden
uns und wir sehen uns später die daher
dass dann sage ich und schüssen